er hat keine ahnung hab ich mich
erschrocken ist ein neuen folgen
gravierend damit kontrakt bei marseille
oder wo bist du
nein ich brauche einen mini schiff da
muss die kurz hier einmal den zeigen wer
der mabo ist aber fordern weiter in die
richtung gleich fatima ich bin grad
durch einen turm und ein schiff durch
gefahren also da musst du einfach in die
richtung für direct dadurch drei okay
ich suche mir auch die idealen ul sind
auf diesem schiff ja das fast immer so
aber die am irgendwo geheim kisten habe
ich gehöre ja festland dann doch nicht
nur eine insel doch festland eine wüste
ist einfach mal geradeaus ja immer
geradeaus
du musst auch teilweise da sodann
durchfahren neu an bord ist kaputt
gegangen
okay ich gehe ungefähren die richtung in
die tour gegangen bist wie sind denn
deine koordinaten das ist das lieber
konkrete droplets alter wassertropfen
koller wie etwas anpflanzen cool weil
meine koordinaten sind - 2600 hier sind
pelikane
ich bin auf dem festland wie knifflig
ist ein pelikan
ich sehe aber nur wenn man kein
konkreter du siehst ja falsch - 2700 und
600 - 2007 rund 600 zb bei 700 x 600
okay findet es aber finde es aber auf
eine rendite die jeden moment wichtig
auch wie schön der welt weiter so
du bist da gar nicht ich bin erwischte
da bist du noch fällig wo da okay kommt
weiter
diese cool water doppelsitze mal vom
mittels digger geil
guck mal dass ein strauß hätte dem
rennen sehen wir den pelikan müsst ist
das pdk der kräftig an
dies sei du musst dir mal mit müssen wir
so leicht anheben kann wieder anlaufen
dass ihr immer du musst du einfach nein
der falschen muss nur einmal boxen guck
doch mal müsst ihr das laufen weil die
läuft kann weiter weiter zustand wir
wollen nämlich das geld wir können aber
den toner kurz machen weil wir wollen
oben lassen das paket das kann man ruhig
denn fast tot
natürlich hatte ich freie last kurz was
fressen
ich kann nichts wegwerfen ich hätte
niemals magnet darauf machen dürfen
ich hab zwar electric ist es nirgendwo
gefunden ich weiß nicht mal wo endlich
als der pyramide dass eine pyramide das
entweder mit weißem sie dann gar nicht
explosion gemacht was explodierte
den hat er den drei top two ich hatte so
angst als ich diese blöde pyramide
gerade drin war
wer der boss ist oben glaube ich
runtergefallen und schießt jetzt als
mögliche ab ja wieso heruntergefallen
oha da ist eine mega heftige pyramide
oha der was denn das eine mega heft die
gebühr anbieten wenn ihr ein flexi mahnt
des kanadiers nico ist die pyramide
geschmack koordinaten butter von einer
tatsächlichen da drauf packen sollen
direkt übernehmen
ja was ist was ist der vermieter nicht
glauben was verbindet den abhang da
jetzt rein
ich will da nicht leiden ich hab angst
angst hat ffh sie morgen kommt der
osterhase konnte nicht konnte er doch
dass das team mir dass libyen ist der
heftige dings wo diese heftigen dings
drin sind die walker bosse glaube ich
sicher ich freue mich sparen einfach ab
doch nicht hinderlich so habe ich mich
erschrocken
oh mein gott oh mein gott ich mich
erschrocken habe ich mich erschrocken
das war eine geste nicht dass du wirst
fast tot oder so richtig versteht sich
sie stand hier eine eckig öffne die so
dass ich behindert denen walter lang als
ist hat geld da ich tue ist vielleicht
ein bisschen dorf juhu ich muss ein
bisschen packen sein dorf das ist ein
echter plasma active smart sich heftig
an
nimm's mit 40 programm jetzt auch von
seiner offen kacke wie ihr habt ja
blöcke hier das ding geht noch viel
weiter das sind ganz viele von den
räumen
ich möchte jetzt mit vier statt gelb
kommen dass mein großer traum
er war weißt du vielleicht sind hier sei
ein falsches unsere einzige chance coole
sachen zu finden
ich laufe schon ein bisschen weiter was
für omega kommt mama jlo angerollt könne
das da ist eine kiste und ich kenn dich
kenn ich glaube ich schon wie ja ich
glaube ich habe schon soviel lasse ich
mir wieder so ein ding machen kann
da sind nur bücher drin
ich suche einfach ein bisschen daher was
den charme einer wolke und wut sind
gleich kaputt den ja ich sagte doch die
halten nicht ewig
mit dem bösen kisten und so glaube ich
trau mich nicht hier ein traum ich nicht
ich hab's ja fast immer die kostenlos
reparieren
nein das weiß ich nicht glaube ich nicht
wo bist du ich bin - 2304 100 - 2300 und
408 - 2300 nein diesen mega schnell die
farmer bedeutend teurer
ich hoffe jetzt kommt noch richtig lange
mehr dann können wir wieder richtig
schön sich eben nur mit dem willen und
biss kann darüber mehr laufen bei 2300
mal so - 2300 500 kommt 408 wieder dem
kader raus weil jetzt wird ja nacht und
das shader besser dichtung ja wie lang
die fragen schon sieben minuten
ich kann erst so schlecht das zeitgefühl
ist genauso wollen muss ich das alles
immer nicht mehr dass ein turm aus sand
ist noch nicht genug noch nie gemacht im
ausland ja mal gucken was da oben los
des rechts feiern die in eine dicke
fette party oder so schon runter das
nicht die kiste kaputt machen
boah das war knapp jetzt trifft blade
rennen dieses komische lieblich keine
ahnung was macht goldenes gesagt der
widerhall darunter geschubst hat man
ohne rüstung ist so heftig ja auch wenn
ich hier nur meine normale dinge an hab
es auch schwierig heftig kommen jedes
jahr umziehen möchte
du gehst in jede ecke rein was du auch
über machen kann es können mal zusammen
statt gelb entdecken
okay wir entdecken die zusammen mit
statt gelb aber ich will mir noch die
oberste kiste hier ja mach das okay und
ich vor was zu essen
beim golden apple können die
schnelligkeit waren gar nicht so
schlechte sachen was ich mit dem boss
lebt er noch
ja das ist eben auf dem boden kommt
jetzt ja ich war mir jedoch die kiste
gerade ich musste ein paar leute kennen
aber nichts gutes mehr außer februar
bekommt ihr denn her okay ich bin aus
dem turm raus und welche muss
weitergehen - 2000 und 0 der der battle
tower golem ist richtig der [ __ ] der
tüte sich einfach selbst gerade - 2009 -
2009 job der mir so eine scheiße das
doch dorf
- 2000 0 - zwar schon wieder fast droht
gerade alter ich der typ box mich ein
ich bin halb tot
ich mache nichts mehr pvp plötzlich ohne
rüstung gar nicht sein - 2009 sind peter
vogel - 2009
ok dann die richtung
ich bin fast taub war diese blöden
schuhe mit ihrer blöden verzauberung ich
bin bei dem mammut so ärgerlich dessen
tower der unter kurdisch geht es um die
besten tower auch den jahren macht den
tower dann gehe ich alleine weiter nein
ich komme schon mit erwarten dass meine
schuhe anziehen kann
ja ich fliege auch gerade einfach nur so
mit dem stab weil die schuhe sind ja
gleich kaputt war ich mir dann lieber
fliegen wie wasser auf oder so oder so
viele untergrund schirme und wir fliegen
einfach zu weit weg
hier ist mehr heißt ja immer noch führen
neuer mehr okay kein mehr richtig immer
weiter fliegt man darf da ich habe ja im
wegpunkte macht eigentlich müsste da ca
statt geld sein ich bin mir zwar nicht
sicher aber eigentlich müssten die genau
da sein weil das ist ja alles unserem
dreieck angeordnet eigentlich müsste
sieht man das nicht auf der karte nivea
noch nie da war sieht man es nicht mehr
was ist das für eine stadt statt gelb
ist die stadt mit debitoren zu ja ich
weiß aber ist das so die vision stadt
oder das ist wald also die wohnung
sollte ja ganz schön versteckt im wald
bestimmt das kann ein neues bio farm ein
stabs kaputt
denn gerade jetzt wo bist du denn gerade
seine koordinaten vielleicht gewinnen
treffen - 1200 und 126 erwarte ich
konnte dir ich habe keine ahnung wo das
hier so ist der falsch gelaufen und 100
längst im kreis ein bisschen gelaufen
und 126 1200 und 126 ja natürlich kommt
zu dir schlafen in die richtung dass auf
einer karte aufgedeckt und ich glaube
das von stadt roth statt dings du bist
total kacke gelaufen der wiso welchem
kreis gelaufen ich so viel drin - 1200
und 126 2 - 1000 euro junge mann was
soll denn das im herbst gesagt du ich
flieg dazu der koordinaten will mit ihr
weiter fliegen dann und jetzt geht es
auf einmal wieder eine andere richtung -
nein die selbe ich will mich den verlust
auf der karte ist das tk oben ich sehe
die stadt schon ehrlich sein job das
lenkrad du musst auf der karte so einen
menschen in einer stadt aber ich glaube
dass die falsche ich guck mal jetzt eben
hier auf der map wir sind auf der hälfte
ca
gerade mal wir sind nicht auf der hälfte
dessen kranke die mir bisher richtig
komisch verschoben
wie das alles sehr merkwürdig hier
es kann ja nicht mal ein bisschen sexy
kölner fans ist ein bestimmtes über 1000
rübergeflogen aber egal michael kessler
essenzen bekommst du im kampf wie ein
echter mann oh herr die gar nicht doch
wir werden auch gejobbt der heckdeckel
diamonds werden geblockt ja eben aber
das ist ja noch das was du aus sex ekel
setzen machst hast doch zum kotzen warum
wo gehen wir jetzt gerade hinzu was für
koordinaten gehst du denn hin
du musst halt wenn du die karte oben
rechts hast mir haben du mitte also
rechts oben sollte mitte sowieso oft
halb zwei halbwegs so weit weg von
zuhause ich finde das traurig meine
schuhe denn gleich kaputt jeden moment
aber es kommt darauf an wo man ist jeden
moment meine schuhe kaputt und dann
laufe ich und dann traurig weil ich dann
langsam bin ich bin so froh wenn man
statt games in das bildportal gesetzt
dann kann ich wieder nach hause meine
schuhe sind kaputt
ich habe keine ersatzschule mit das
heißt eine rüstung ist nicht mehr voll
online alter ich brauche mir den
mexikaner zinsen leichten start gehen im
umlauf fühlt sich das auch wieder
richtig richtig langsam an
sonst bekommen wir einfach statt gelb
hawo ist de ich weiß noch gar nicht sagt
mal wo du bist gerade deine koordinaten
ok - bei null
mir ist bei null genau null und 650 adam
ich sofort da warte tür im moment ich
möchte aber nicht hingekommen bin 550
und 650 h0 und 650,00 1000 kommt zu
kommt zu ja kommt zu null und haut -
tausende 50 - 1000 - 1050 bis zu dem
durchaus entgegen er müsse doch ich
werde laufen sollte dann kommt mir auch
ein bisschen entgegen doch wir sind
vielleicht sogar schon da denkst du
unsere stadt aber wahlweise drei viertel
gelaufen weil ich da ca dem ich habe
einen punkt auf die karte gesetzt wo wir
hin müssen
und woher weißt du dass es da ist weil
die stätten im dreieck angeordnet sind
in dementsprechend müsste dann dauert
circa statt geld seien ja ganz ungefähr
habe eigentlich müsste das so sein würde
da ist die stadt eisenstadt und dann ist
eine stadt der das müsste zu sein
eigentlicher da ich mein flug stadt
verbracht
du bist du den
gerade habe ich nicht noch irgendwie ein
ich bin jetzt bei - top - ich hab sogar
noch ein flug statt sondern kannst du
fliegen
aber mein erster weg schon als er schon
weniger als hälfte ja ich bin schon 2003
- 400 euro habe ich schnell flug
star-power lange die folge schon 16
minuten
ok lexika list and you - 700 oder ist
also ein fetter baum alter.de möchte
jetzt mal fällen geht dann wohl
irgendwas passiert dann irgendwas lecter
servern oder so oh mein gott oh mein
gott
ein dialekt passiert nichts ich bin bei
- 1000 passiert nichts wenn ich den
abbau ich bin ist bei - 1000 ehrlich
gesagt ehrlich ja was ich von mir gut
finden
bei - 1100 sogar seinen rosa baum mit
seinem rosa baum ja ich habe ich packs
bisschen verschätzt
bin gleich da nicht sehe den riesenbaum
gleich den moment x50 ja wenn ich jetzt
und z ist - 1070 bei mir - 1150 sehe ich
aber nicht sehe ich nicht jetzt auch im
rausch abbauen und füchse in china
ich bei dir einfluss da ja jetzt kommt
in diese richtung geht mein flug stopp
ist praktisch kaputt meine schuhe ebenso
muss bisschen essen und trinken ja das
bringt aber lieber das schön ruppig und
von meiner hier
oder ich gehe dahin und machte einen
portal und dann bin ich da er wisse
nichts geändert
bleibt nun mal nicht ja ich laufe jetzt
nochmal mit dem weiter wo bist du denn
jetzt meine ich gerade und von daher
sehe ich noch heute hast du das hinter
mir bleiben
ja ich musste kurz das austauschen ich
bin bei 200.000 - 1200 1 200 200 und -
1200 - 200 soll es gleichzeitig legen
ok go go go kommen jetzt so lange weiter
bis ein großer stab geburt ist ein
alligator ali alligator
wo sind denn die boxee kahles enden
ja ich würde auch gerne in die stadt
gekostet sagt ja kommt mit den statt
gelb hat er gesagt er hat gesagt toll
werden hat er gesagt
jetzt kommen ist aber dass nicht die
glaub ich nee ich war auch schon 1000
städten und monster nicht aber die sieht
auch voll geil aus hier so direkt am ab
ich dachte statt 2000 ungefähr weil ich
ja keine ahnung aber jetzt sind wir hier
mich wann ist es gerne jeder moment ich
habe mal kurz eine kleine idee und zwar
kennt aber bei den anderen kurs bei den
koordinaten copen stadt ist das ist
nichts kaputt machen also dürfen wir
auch nicht warum die anderen muss ich
halt auch die stadt überhaupt versucht
uns zuhört habe ich auch so ist
guckst du den video an
vivas moment
ich habe spaß
ich will spaß ich egal da warte ich hab
die koordinaten doch nicht auch man
jetzt haben die hier keine koordinaten
wir können da die debitoren eventuell
koordinaten haben oder der jeep keine
ahnung vielleicht in der ersten folge
haben sie es irgendwann ausgemacht
euro minecraft terror
die hat auch keine folge der immer zu
hause ist
da die erste folge wahrscheinlich stimmt
das kann sein dass sie klug an denen so
war
ich finde hier aber nichts der
straßenverkehr
das ist nix co wer keine folge zu hause
gemacht auch die erste
da
lassen die koordinaten schreibt über
ganz kurzen chat ja ich bin gespannt
ich werde ihn so richtig weiß dass
erstens 311 das andere - 5100 meter so
weit so voll gut 5000 blöcke nur
trotzdem relativ weiter schauen wir
nicht mehr dieser folge 300 ja die folge
sei schon vorbei okay wir wollen uns nun
am nächsten folge probieren wenn euch
gefallen hat und wir in der nächsten
folge werden weiter suchen sollen dann
lasst einfach eine bewertung gab dann
will ich sagen auf den start gehe
wir treffen uns an den start